before he was secretary of
transportation a presidential candidate
or even the mayor of south bend indiana
pete buttigieg got his start working
in finance after graduating from harvard
and oxford
buda judge took up a job as an analyst
at mckinsey in 2007
making about a hundred and fifty
thousand dollars a year the job needed
him to be on the road during the week so
eventually he moved back home to south
bend where he bought a fixer-upper home
for a hundred and twenty-five thousand
dollars in two thousand eight
buddha josh eventually grew tired of
consulting and made his way into
politics with a failed run for india and
a state treasurer
the campaign burned through much of his
life savings but buddhist wasn't done
with politics yet
while earning just seven thousand
dollars in 2011 he mounted a campaign
for the mayor of south bend indiana
and one mayor pete as he'd become to be
known
took office on january 1st 2012 and once
again was making a steady salary
making a hundred and seven thousand
dollars and a hundred and sixteen
thousand
the following two years then in 2014
mayor pete who was also a navy reservist
was deployed to afghanistan to serve in
intelligence
his mission was working with a unit to
block drug funding for insurgents
that year he took a pay cut earning 46
thousand dollars
he returned to south bend seven months
later where he reclaimed office and
eventually married his husband chase and
glozman a junior high teacher at the
time
in the early days of the 2020
presidential campaign the buddha
judges were estimated to be worth about
a hundred thousand dollars
but as mayor pete's campaign and the
national profile grew
so did their fortune with the couple
bringing in over a million dollars
according to forbes estimates
pete published his first book in 2019
earning him seventy five thousand
dollars in advances and just over
four hundred thousand dollars in pre-tax
royalties
his next book published seven months
after he dropped out of the race earned
him over three hundred thousand dollars
in advances
with at least a hundred thousand more to
come before joining president biden's
cabinet pete took a number of smaller
gigs
he was first brought on as a fellow at
notre dame earning 37
000 in six months before signing on as a
podcast host at iheart radio for a
minimum guaranteed payment of a hundred
and fifty thousand dollars
jason also wrote a book and sold over 20
000 copies after quitting his job as a
teacher
the buddha judges also bought a lakeside
vacation home in traverse city michigan
for 415 000
taking out a 332 000 mortgage in the
process
now as the transportation secretary pete
earns over 200 000
a year settled in dc he sold his south
bend home three months ago for three
hundred and ten thousand dollars
more than double his initial investment
forbes estimates conservatively that the
buddha judges are now worth at least
seven hundred and fifty thousand dollars
you